monsieur frantz fanon il accède enfin au
graal suprême jusqu alors premier
danseur françois à lui est passé dans
une autre dimension en devenant danseur
étoile de l'opéra de paris une
consécration j'ai pas vraiment réalisé
puisque c'est toujours un moment un peu
un peu suspendue en plus il y avait
toute ma famille dans la salle mes amis
mon équipe mon amour tout le monde était
présent donc c'est sûr que c'est un
moment de célébration un moment où will
chose d'un peu inédit qui se passe c'est
un sacre mais un sacre de pas simplement
de la danse c'est vraiment ça c'est une
consécration de
presque d'un parcours de vie un parcours
de vie pas si classique et une
silhouette atypique si les danseurs de
l'opéra sont reconnaissables à leur
allure filiforme françois lui est plus
athlétique et impressionne par ses
pirouettes et c'est tour en l'air il ya
encore quelques années les toilettes est
encore loin l'étoile vous y pensez aux
pas vraiment à vrai dire moi ce qui m'a
ce qui me ce qui me touche le plus c'est
surtout de faire des spectacles comme ça
d'aller à la rencontre des gens de
d'être au contact d'artistes et de
chorégraphe voilà c'est ici que tout a
commencé pour françois ces qualités ont
été décelés très tôt par sa mère
professeur de danse à fut si dans le
cher à 10 ans il rentre à l'école de
l'opéra de paris après avoir passé de
nombreuses heures sur ce parquet au sous
sol de la maison familiale c'était le
même enseignement mais ça change pas la
barre ça reste la barre avec des
mouvements qui diffèrent mais le dégager
toujours là le glisser du vél plier le
temps du le relever on le retrouve à
toutes les sauces voilà françois à lui
s'inscrire aussi de la danse hip hop
quand il fait du classique une culture
qui le rapproche de son frère ça lui
permet d'avoir une approche plus
complémentaire ou le classique c'est
plus normé vous avoir les épaules basses
toujours bien se tenir alors que
l'époque on va chercher différentes
sources d'inspiration et c'est une
culture donc ça lui permet d'avoir une
belle ouverture d'esprit je pense à côté
d'or classic après le foot la gym ou
encore le judo françois à lui a
finalement chaussé les pointes avec un
rêve qui ne l'a jamais quitté faire
comme patrick dupont heureusement que
j'ai passée patrick dumas je crois que
ces moments qui va qui vient montrer des
vidéos de patrick dupont il a essayé il
n'a pas bougé qui met ses sacs se faire
- c'est ça en plus de danser il fait
aussi du cinéma écrit et tourna one man
show cette étoile arrive finalement au
moment où il s'y attendait le moins un
couronnement dans sa liberté d'artiste